يوما بعد اخر تتطرق وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه الى خلافات ربما لم تكن تتطرق
اليها من قبل النقاشات كذلك في وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه بدات في التطرق الى
مواضيع كان مسكوتا عنها مع بدايه الحرب
على اعتبار ان
هذه يعني حاله حرب تفترض تماسك المجتمع
وما الى ذلك
لكن السؤال الان هل تعتقد ان هذا سينعكس
في
صوره تزايد لحركه الاحتجاجات في الشارع
على الطريقه التي ضار بها العمليه
برمتها بالتاكيد هذا الامر هو ينعكس فعلا
في يعني المساله عموما يعني في العدوان
الحربي على قطاع غزه في البدايه كما تفضلت
كان هناك نوع من الاجماع او قدر واضح من
الاجماع على هذه الحرب العدوانيه على قطاع
غزه لم يكن هناك حاله نقديه كان هناك
اراده واضحه لدى الجميع باظهار الوحده
والتماسك في هذه الحرب التي وصفت بانها
وجوديه وتمكنت المؤسسه السياسيه والعسكريه
من حشد كل المجتمع الاسرائيلي اسراي خلفها
لكن في الحقيقه مع مجموعه من الامور
المهمه بدا الموقف يتغير صحيح هذا الموقف
لم يتغير الى الدرجه التي من الممكن ان
نعدها حاسمه في تغيير مجريات هذه الحرب
ولكن هذا الموقف تغير بقدر يعني قابل
للقياس
وبقدر ظاهر وملاحظ ينبغي ان يؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار المجتمع الاسرائيلي نفسه في
الحقيقه توسعت فيه شرائح واطياف لها موقف
من هذه الحرب سواء الموقف الرافض للحرب
عموما والذي يدعو الى وقف هذه الحرب او
الموقف الذي يعتقد ضروره اعطاء الاولويه
للاسرى ثم تستانف هذه الحرب في وقت لاحق
او الموقف الذي يقدم قراءه نقديه ورؤيه
نقديه لمجريات هذهه الحرب نحن في البدايه
كان في هناك امر مستغرب صحيح ان هناك
دائما يعني رقابه عسكريه تضبط النقاش
العسكري وتضبط النقاش السياسي اثناء الحرب
ولكن حتى ال الطرح النقدي الذي يعني يروم
ويريد في النتيجه تحسين اداء الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذا توقف في البدايه في
الحقيقه حتى لا يفهم ان يعني هذا الموقف
من ش شانه ان يفت من عضد الجيش الاسرائيلي
نحن الان نلاحظ قراءات نقديه كثيره كتابات
نقديه كثيره في الصحافه الاسرائيليه سواء
في اداء الجيش الاسرائيلي سواء في الاهداف
العسكريه والسياسيه المعلنه سواء في اداره
بنيامين نتنياهو هذا الامر لا يقتصر فقط
على الكتابه في الصحافه الاسرائيليه ولكن
ايضا هناك اصوات استراتيجيه مهمه في دوله
الكيان الاسرائيلي بدات تتحدث في كل هذه
النقاط وكل هذه الملفات نتحدث عن الرؤساء
وزراء سابقين نتحدث عن قيادات عسكريه
وامنيه سابقه وهذا فيما يتعلق بالموضوع من
الناحيه المباشره يعني من ناحيه موضوعيه
من الناحيه من ناحيه مهنيه لكن بالتاكيد
هناك ايضا اعتبارات اخرى يعني موجوده في
الوسط السياسي الاسرائيلي وموجوده ايضا
بين منيمين نتنياهو ما بين القياده
العسكريه والامنيه هناك تصفيه حسابات
شخصيه هناك الخلافات المعارضه او
الاختلافات التي كانت موجوده قبل هذه
الحرب هي باتت تفرض نفسها في هذه الحرب
الجميع يريد ان ينجي نفسه من من المسؤوليه
عن هذه الحرب يعني الخلاف ما بين بنيامين
نتنياهو والجيش والامن يظهر بين فتره
واخرى في تحمل المسؤول مسوليه عن احداث س
تشرين اكتوبر ايضا في هناك نوع من الضرب
تحت الحزام او هناك هناك نوع من اللعب تحت
الطاوله يعني بمعنى جانتس وايزن جووت واذا
كنا نتحدث عن جانتس صحيح انه يريد ان
يتصرف بصوره مهنيه في مجلس الحرب وان يظهر
يعني المسؤوليه تجاه معركه يصفونها بانها
معركه وجوديه ولكنها يدرك تماما ان
بنيامين تنياه يريد ان يستغل وان يتغطى
بمجلس الحرب لاسباب واهداف شخصيه حتى
جنرالات الجيش الذين يريدون استمرار هذه
الحرب ولكنهم ايضا يعتقدون ان بنيامين
نتنياهو يريد ان يكود هذه الحرب ايضا يعني
لاسباب
لاهداف
شخصيه في خض هذه الخلافات تبرز بعض
الاسئله ماذا
يعني انسحاب بيني جانس وايزن كوت من مجلس
الحرب اذا حدث ذلك كذلك ماذا يعني انسحاب
بين كفير
و و سموتريتش من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بالنسبه لنتنياهو اذا حدث هذا اذا تفاقمت
الخلافات و حدث
هذا هذا يعني الشيء الكثير في الحقيقه على
اكثر من مستوى المستوى الاول اسرائيل
ارادت ان تظهر نوع من الوحده الوطنيه في
اداره هذه الحرب التي وصفتها بانها حرب
وجوديه ووصفتها بانها استمرار لحرب
الاستقلال وكان استقلال اسرائيل لم ينجز
حتى هذه اللحظه ومن ثم تفكك مجلس الحرب
باي شكل من الاشكال او تفكك الوسط السياسي
الاسرائيلي باي شكل من الاشكال سواء كان
انسحاب ايزنكوت او بني جانتس او انسحاب
احزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه وما يسمى بالعظمه
اليهوديه هذا يعني ان اسرائيل لم تعد
واحده ولم تعد متماسكه ومن ثم هذه ضربه
مهمه جدا على المستوى المعنوي والتعبوي
والاجتماعي والسياسي والاستراتيجي بالنسبه
للكيان الاسرائيلي هذا فيما يتعلق بالصوره
العامه ولكن اذا كنا نريد ان نتحدث عن
حيثيات سياسيه وتفاصيل سياسيه بنيامين
نتنياهو اراد ان يتغطى بمثل جانت
بالمعارضه الاسرائيليه اصلا في هذه
المعركه حتى لا يحمل يعني وحده مسؤوليه اي
قرارات خاطئه في اداره هذه الحرب واضح
تماما ان نيتنياهو يريد ان يفرض وجهه نظره
ويريد ان يفرض ادارته على هذه الحرب بما
في ذلك حتى القرارات العسكريه والسياسيه ا
والامنيه التي يفترض كما تفضلتم في
الاشاره في التقارير منع احيانا الرئيس
المساد او رئيس الشباك من مناقشه بعض
القضايا الامنيه او منع جانتس وا ايزنكوت
او مجلس الحرب من مناقشه اليوم التالي
بطبيعه الحال هذه مغالطه حينما تحدث بن
كفير ان سؤال اليوم التالي هو سؤال سياسي
ينبغي ان تدير الحكومه الاصليه القائمه
وليس مجلس الحرب الذي له اهداف يعني
عسكريه وهذا كلام غير دقيق لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يريد ان يدير عملياته بص يعني
وفق اهداف سياسيه قابله للعقل نه وقابله
للفهم وقابله للتطبيق بطبيعه ايه الحال
ومن ثم بنيامين نتنياهو يريد ان يتغطى
بهؤلاء حتى لا يحمل وحده مسؤوليه اي اخطاء
سياسيه وكي يوزع الاخطاء السياسيه على
الاخرين بطبيعه الحال فضلا عن ان انسحاب
ايزنكوت او بن جانسي يكشف بنيامين نتنياهو
لانه اصلا هناك انقسام على بنيامين
نتنياهو بسبب تحالفه مع الصهيونيه الدينيه
وبسبب تحالفه مع يعني ال الاحزاب يعني
سواء احزاب الحريديم او احزاب الصهيونيه
الدينيه وبالتالي انسحاب تلك المعارضه
وانسحاب الكفاءات والخبرات العسكريه من
مجلس الحرب يعني انكشاف بنيامين نتنياهو
يعني زياده الانقسام على شخص بنيامين
نتنياهو يعني شكرا تحقق الخساره السياسيه
لبنيامين نتنياهو